oui non mais sérieux on confirme que ça
véhicule débat gala d'hier au soir vous
n'avez contaminé personnelle et vous
vous dites quand même
oui d'où le doubs la laine une sortie au
nom des six mais c'est nul c'est
franchement pas j'avoue j'aime aussi la
boue c'est bon c'est bon j'ai échappé
une prise d'otages
à votre avis evelyne j'ai une chape et
j'ai échappé une prise d'otages à l'epa
géraldine parce qu'elle vous regardait
que c'est moi géraldine jean michel
maire en cause la sécurité des maïs ou
tomate à louer dans la grosse tête
soleil oui non c'est en 2008 j'étais au
figaro que j'étais en reportage dont le
sol indien
ces tests ont interviewé s'est pas
mouillé pas posé la question et leurs
bateaux depuis le début mon territoire
et accéléré on n'a rien fait et fin mars
début avril 2008 dans l'océan indien
j'étais choix comme ça c'était où
c'était où c'est au large de madagascar
mais c'est donc l océan on dirait mon
orthophoniste et j'ai débarqué ont
débarqué nos cités à odos
[Rires]
c'est pas moi
nous on ne peut pas être ça je suis
descendu du bateau le bateau aurait
appareillé le lendemain il est reparti
pour la méditerranée au large de la
somalie ont été attaqués par des pirates
il ya eu trente personnes à bord la
prise d'otage a duré plusieurs jours il
ya eu des blessés les forces françaises
spéciales ont attaqué les pirates
voilà pour récupérer une partie de la
rançon ça fait la une des journaux et
j'étais dans le bateau deux jours avant
du coup j'étais bien placé pour dans le
figaro raconte l'histoire va écouter bas
bercy bravo jean michel voyou pas l
habitude
[Applaudissements]